how many people watching this was a huge
fan of the walking dead franchise the
life is strange franchise there is a lot
of different avenues that we had
opportunities with in the past that was
kind of a point-and-click feature that
really gravitated and grabbed our
attention got a game for you guys today
it's called as dust falls for the xbox
series x i reviewed it on that platform
but before we get on with the review if
you guys enjoy podcast definitely
subscribe to the channel we do a podcast
every sunday the iron lords podcast and
i do my own podcast every wednesday on
this channel call the attic show and
without any further ado here is my
review on as dust falls for the xbox
series x
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord adam
coming at you for another review today
we're going to be reviewing as dust
falls for the xbox series x developed by
interior knight and published by xbox
game studios first off let's give a
little bit in depth on what type of game
this is this game is pretty much like
the life is strange you know the walking
dead it has that point-and-click kind of
feature that involves the story
depending on the choices that you make
during your playthrough and it can
evolve from whatever type of play
through you do for instance you can
really try to elevate one character over
another just depending on what kind of
player you are and the choices you make
during the game first thing let's talk
about is the artwork in this game in
general i will admit when i first
started this i wasn't a big fan of the
artwork that they have chosen for as
dust falls it's kind of like a comic
book where you turn the page it gives
like slight adjustments to the artwork
but it isn't a full-blown motion it's
always like you know turning the page
and they'll slightly turn their head
left or you know the grass will
constantly be going back and forth but
what i will admit in this game is after
you play a couple chapters or maybe even
just the chapter for me it was about two
chapters you kind of end up seeing the
game where i think the developers wanted
you to see where at first you see these
these little motions that the characters
and the backgrounds make but then
eventually after you play a little bit
of the game you start seeing it in your
mind the way that an actual movie would
be playing and i think that's the way
they originally designed like comic
books and stuff where you know they give
you this inspiration that's on these
papers or on the game or on the screen
and you start to slowly subconsciously
see what you're reading on the actual
screen happening in your head and i have
to give them props for that because i'm
a very
very critical person when it comes to
artwork and how i want things done and
and i was completely against the way
this game showed itself at first but i
will admit it did grow on me it grew on
me pretty good and by the end of the
game i was very pleased by the artwork
of this game like i said it's not for
everyone i'm not gonna say that you
gotta play five six hours of the game to
really
see the artwork come to life but i will
say you know try the first chapter i
feel like if you guys are on here and
you at least try that first chapter
you'll be more willing now let's talk
about the gameplay as dust falls now i
will mention to you the gameplay in this
game is the point-and-click thing that
you would get from the life of strange
and you would get from the walking dead
franchise but there is some caveats that
they put into this that make a lot of
sense you guys know that i don't really
go into story a whole lot so i want to
warn you the background's not going to
have a whole lot of aspects of the game
in terms of story i might put some you
know stuff that happened at the
beginning but i don't want to really
ruin the story for you guys but when it
comes to the gameplay and the story they
kind of go hand to hand the story has a
lot of aspects that the gameplay takes
advantage of that is unique to just this
game that you don't really see in other
franchises for instance when you're
going through certain aspects of this
game there will be key components of the
story where you cannot negotiate with
people it is either everyone is the
majority vote or you have to use these
things called overrides well it's pretty
much saying that i don't care what this
person over here said i don't care what
this person over there says i want this
story to go the way i want it to go any
time can i stay with you
it's not good i'll talk to michelle
i kind of want to just shut him down
you're overriding
[Laughter]
you always
take it up with your life
so use an override what's an override
addict an override is something that one
to eight players can use in as dust
falls and when i say eight i mean eight
of your friends or seven of your friends
can play this game simultaneously with
you and there's actual a broadcast mode
to where if you're a streamer and you
guys really want to find good streaming
games because i think you know we don't
have a whole lot of games that appeal to
an audience of a streamer but this is a
game that really helps do that now i
will admit i didn't get a plate myself i
don't know if it was active at the time
but i do know that for the most part the
way it was wording it to me was you when
you're playing this your audience has a
vote on what's going on in the game and
i think that's that's relatively a cool
thing
back to the overrides what i like about
the overrides is
it causes a little bit of friction
between the players that you're playing
this with now if it's not those key
components at the very end of the
chapters they're not at the very end of
the chapters there are a couple
sprinkled through the chapters but if
it's not those specific choices there's
a lot of time sensitive choices and
you've seen that in life is strange in
the walking dead word the developer
doesn't really want to give you time to
really look at these options and see
which ones gonna fit for you so what do
they do they give you maybe five to ten
seconds to really choose what you want
sometimes even less than that for the
most part the majority of the game does
have that time structure one but when
you get to these key moments where
they're forcing you to argue with your
person that you're playing this game
with or with multiple people and then
let's say that you don't agree with them
you use that override you get what you
want anyway but you only got a certain
amount of those overrides and keep in
mind the other players can use their
overrides to override your override
[Music]
is it worth sitting down and talking
wait what kiss i feel like we're not
getting like sit and talk
but where is the
get out of my
leave right there there's the one i want
no because they're supposed to be
no
so sometimes maybe it's not the best
thing to fight for your actual one
because you'll end up getting to a
situation where you can't override
theirs later because you spent all of
yours overriding yours at the beginning
and i had that happen to me a couple
times where i would want to override the
people i'm playing it with but it's not
necessarily the best interest in me
because i need some of those overrides
for later on in the chapter and i
honestly do feel like that is one of the
biggest perspectives of as dust falls
that makes it unique compared to games
like the walking dead and life is
strange there's a few other ones but
those are the biggest ones to me and i
do think that that's one of the key
aspects that make this game fun like i
said i didn't play the broadcast mode
but the way it was described i feel like
that's going to really resonate with a
lot of especially twitch streamers it
did look like it was only twitch
streamers youtube needs to get on that
they need to make sure more of those
kind of features come to their platform
but you know for the most part there was
only one real big thing i didn't like
about this game and that was the
ui the menus i felt like some of them
was redundant like they would always ask
you you know press the x if you don't
want to see this pop up again and i get
that that is a good option to have but
they would literally have you go to
where you would start it you would do a
co-op session then you would have to
click online
and then you have to invite and every
time you start this no matter what
chapter you're on you would have to go
through the tutorial pretty much of you
know just like a a sure it wasn't that
much you just pushed a a bunch of times
and you would start it but after playing
this three or four hours and doing this
like the third or fourth time of a play
through sitting down on on a play
through those little things was getting
on my nerves especially when you know
didn't happen a lot maybe once where
something would happen and there would
be a disconnect with my partner i would
have to go through that process again to
re-send out invites to start that game
again and i think you know if the
developers are watching this go in there
and and make sure that you know you can
go somewhere else to watch that where
you don't have to constantly remind
players like i said sure you give them
the option to disable it which i think
for the most part a lot of you are going
to look past this fact but like i said
even to just initiate a multiplayer
session you have to go to a multiplayer
session then you have to click the
profile that you want then when you get
on the actual screen that you would say
yo i can send out invites you have to go
over there and scroll and click online
like i just think it's a lot of extra
steps for no reason and i think that's
the only road knick-knack i have for
this game it's does falls is a good game
they do have a feature with tablets on
here where if you don't have a
controller and you want to get those
eight people everyone's got tablets you
know maybe not everyone's got a console
but a lot of people have a smartphone
have a tablet have something that they
can download on the apple store download
on the google store and they do have an
app on there that wasn't available
during this review process it might be
available while i'm recording this
review but it wasn't available during
the initial reviewing process and i have
a little nick to pull out that if like
you're gonna get features that you want
me to speak of on a review kind of make
sure that they work but that's neither
here or there definitely go and download
that because i think it would be a lot
more easier to do that than everyone
have a controller these controllers are
expensive you know and if you have a
phone where you can easily
access the game where you can play up to
eight people i think that's a lot more
accessible than everyone having a
controller but you know what that's the
review on as dust falls like i said
games got a unique art style that i grew
to love towards the middle to the end of
the game it's got a fantastic story that
is branching past there was some endings
that i saw had three or four endings to
that chapter not to mention when you
keep going further and further in the
story those possibilities just continue
to increase and it's got actually really
good functionability when it comes to
multiplayer you can play with your
friends and i do think this game's got a
lot of replay value but that's pretty
much my review on his death falls i
played it on the xbox series x i do
think it's worth your money like i said
it's in game pass so definitely go
download it if you want to try it in
that and until next time this is lord
addict and that was my review and this
game definitely gets an iron lord stamp
peace